hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge now I know there's been some
talk out there oh the try not to laugh
videos they're just mark laughing for 10
minutes straight well hey aho first I'll
my pride and then number two how dare
you I ain't gonna be tolerating any of
that [ __ ] talk anymore I'm gonna be
doing this particular try not to laugh
and if I even crack a smile I will
I bet again I bet then I'm not gonna
laugh and if I do if I do then Tyler and
Ethan can punish me again maybe if I
crack a smile that'll be okay but we'll
play it by ear okay cool all right sound
good alright here we go
[Music]
not funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
nope not funny
not what I would call funny not funny I
want to know what this is done you're
I'm gonna kick your ass
what's the power of man's brain
boom did somebody say the same enemy
that it was just referred to but I have
no idea
[Music]
my daddy taught me a few things too like
how not rip the skin by using someone
else's mouth steady your own hands no
not funny and then laugh that was on the
last
[Music]
nope nah funny not funny
[Laughter]
that guy just shot that other guy
immediately in the face I had nothing to
do with it there was an argument it was
like a workplace argument these red
dudes had snow soldiers gonna as
soldiers guys tight tolerances no I'm so
scared I'm so scared I know exactly what
you're looking for what is it
don't is it long
[Music]
it wasn't real laughs it wasn't a real
one I forgot what I was doing I got
caught up in the moment that wasn't a
real laughs don't count that one
[Music]
[Applause]
nope
[Music]
[Laughter]
you are great
when is your violin concert June 15th
what's the day today June 11 you come to
my concert good not bad there he really
knew me proud all right okay I lost
again
oh boy I was recording a video and I I
was recording try not to laugh and I bet
that I wouldn't laugh at it and I
laughed I mean not if you don't make her
another punishment go for it okay it
sounds like you sound like the count
from Sesame Street oh you were right I
was wrong
I laughed it's my fault so we'll see
about that punishment later huh so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you enjoyed this let me know down in the
comments below you want to see another
one let me know in the comments below as
well and if you have suggestions for
funny clips put those down there thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye